una victoria diplomática para el
gobierno de lópez obrador la justicia
estadounidense desestimó los cargos de
tráfico de drogas y lavado de activos
contra el secretario de defensa de
méxico salvador cienfuegos el giro
judicial se dio a pedido del gobierno de
eeuu que accedió a que cienfuegos
regrese a mexico y sea juzgado en su
país el ejecutivo mexicano celebró la
decisión esto establece un precedente
en materia de cooperación entre los dos
países la cooperación con los eeuu se
fundamenta y debe hacerlo siempre en el
respeto mutuo
a nuestra soberanía de nuestras
instituciones sin fuego se volverá de
inmediato a méxico y será puesto a
disposición de las autoridades
judiciales de su país aunque no
permanecerá detenido
el presidente mexicano prometió que el
exfuncionario será juzgado de manera
debida no hay impunidad
el para nadie
y al mismo tiempo no vamos a permitir en
ningún caso
que se fabriquen de leeds cienfuegos el
secretario de defensa de enrique peña
nieto fue detenido en los ángeles y
luego trasladado a nueva york- era
acusado de estar implicado en la
producción tráfico y distribución de
marihuana metanfetamina cocaína y
heroína entre 2015 y 2017 cargos que él
niega
en mexico algunos ciudadanos temen que
el militar quede impune
sin fuego se también estaba a cargo de
defensa cuando ocurrió la desaparición
de los 43 estudiantes de acho china para
un grupo de personas se movilizó a la
costa federal en brooklyn para pedir que
cienfuegos también sea juzgado por esos
hechos